[Music]
hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me
so i'm currently working on three
scripted videos for this channel a video
on the book of the new sun by gene wolfe
a video on the dispossessed by ursula k
le guin and the video on sixteen laws
three body problem series specifically
the deterrent era but in this video i
wanted to answer a particular question
about that series three body the
remembrance of earth's past that i get
constantly
since i started uploading videos about
the three body problems series and that
question is
why did the trisolarins
choose earth out of all the planets in
the galaxy why did they pick earth
specifically
the answer is
they didn't choose earth
we chose them
so keep in mind and i can't believe that
i have to say this but this series is
science fiction
because i get a shocking amount of
comments of people complaining that a
science fiction book isn't 100
scientifically accurate so these books
are science fiction and in these books
humanity is able to boost a signal into
outer space by kind of slingshotting the
signal
across the sun and that has the effect
of magnifying the signal so it can reach
far greater distances now humans in this
book just like humans in the real world
are very interested in whether or not
they're the only species out there
they're trying to contact
other worlds other life by sending
signals out into outer space
now that being said i have to make the
point that in a lot of classic works of
science fiction when we encounter alien
life the depiction of both humanity and
the aliens is usually homogeneous you
have the humans who are homogeneous and
united under one goal survive the aliens
and you have the aliens who are also
homogeneous and they all just want to
destroy the world conquer humanity
whatever it is but in three body problem
it's a bit different because humans
don't all want the same things and
neither do the tricelerans and that is
where the character yawinji comes into
play and she can almost be viewed as the
villain of this first book in the series
so like i said humanity sent messages
out friendly messages in vague
directions
and eventually
they got a message back
and it was a very simple
message
it said do not answer
do not
answer
and that was followed up by a second
message
this world has received your message
i am a pacifist in this world
it is the luck of your civilization that
i am the first to receive your message
i am warning you
do not answer do not answer do not
answer
there are tens of millions of stars in
your direction as long as you do not
answer this world will not be able to
ascertain the source of your
transmission
but if you do answer
the source will be located right away
your planet will be invaded your world
will be conquered
do not answer
do not answer
do not answer
now to understand how the character
yawinji responded when she received this
message you have to understand that this
is a character who feels betrayed by
humanity she feels wronged by humanity
she's suffered great injustices her
father was taken away from her and she
just feels as though
the world
is in a good place under the rule of
humanity she has such disdain for
humanity and really just like no hope
in the human race
so it's a twisted
turn of fate that she was the one to
first receive this message because
although
the listener who sent this message all
the way from tri solaris
back to earth
told her not to answer do not answer
clearly do not respond because that will
give away your location she responded
and her message was
also very simple
come here
i will help you conquer this world
our civilization is no longer capable of
solving its own problems
we need your force to intervene
and so yaowinji
over the course of decades
while the majority of the world has no
idea that these aliens are even on their
way
has actually been developing this
organization called eto earth trisolaris
organization and they've been helping
the tricelerians do their bidding on
earth so as i said earlier if your
question is why they chose us they
didn't choose us we chose them because
humanity is not one homogenous group if
aliens were coming you can pretty much
guarantee there would be some humans
that would be on the side of the aliens
because there's always some humans that
have weird opinions about stuff
so
try solaris
when presented with this world that's
only four light years away and they
don't need to bother terraforming it or
anything
and they've even got supporters on earth
they said yeah we're gonna go and we're
gonna send ships to earth and we're
gonna conquer them because their planet
has three sons and it's very chaotic
they've evolved to survive but they're
surviving but they're not living and
because they are an intelligent species
they kind of intuitively know that there
can be more there can be a better life
and earth to them looks like an absolute
paradise because it is and humans often
take for granted the fact that we live
on basically a paradise world
so this series isn't just depicting a
war between humans and aliens it's
depicting a war between the differing
societal values of the human race
what is good what is bad what is right
what is wrong what is the best for
humanity moving forward should humanity
even move forward at all these books are
about the battle for the very soul
of the human race the very essence of
humanity who are we in the end
what is left when it's all over when the
solar system has faded into dust
and the sun has gone out what is left
what is our legacy
and that's pretty much why the series is
called the remembrance of earth's past i
think because those are pretty heavy
themes especially in the last book
that's sinned so i think that pretty
much answers the question
in as concise a manner as i possibly can
so i hope you guys
like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas if you're interested in science
fiction books hit up my channel it's the
place to be thanks guys
[Music]
foreign